bonjour à toutes bonjour à tous Nous
sommes très heureux d'être avec vous ce
matin vous regardez votre nouvelle
matinale sur NCI le 6/9 du lundi au
vendredi nous allons prendre le temps
pour tenter de mieux comprendre
l'actualité
de la rentrée
même si il y a de la casse venez nous
verrez pas debout pendant quelques
semaines encore Adeline s'est cassé le
pied elle est tombée du camping
c'est un aspect bonjour à tous et
bienvenue pour cette huitième saison qui
commence de l'heure des pros miracle
alléluia la Baya sera interdite à
l'école le gouvernement a une
illumination cet été pas de tenue
religieuse à l'école nous devons faire
bloc et nous allons faire bloc faire
bloc c'est être clair et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire la Baya n'a pas sa
place dans nos écoles pas plus que des
signes religieux j'observe que nous
l'avions dit ici toute la saison
dernière que n'avons-nous entendu
raciste xénophobe extrême droite il
s'agissait simplement d'un peu de bon
sens bon sens qui semble avoir touché la
les épreuves du bac n'auront plus lieu
en mars mais en juin deuxième miracle la
macronie
à découvrir resteront mes amis cette
saison bah écoutez c'est la première
bonne nouvelle de la rentrée Alexandra
je vous fais un énorme bisou et aussi
pardon un bisou Alexandrie aussi
alors c'est la personne la soufflé
mais concrètement qu'est-ce qu'une
abeille il s'agit d'une longue robe
couvrant les jambes et les bras un
vêtement considéré par le gouvernement
comme une atteinte à la laïcité
lorsqu'il est porté à l'école
cette lycéenne de confession musulmane
le porte mais pas pour des raisons
religieuses dit-elle
c'est comme si c'était un habit normal
je suis en mode une robe mais juste
c'est tout Marie Marie tu voulais nous
montrer une image du président ça va
tranquille ouais c'est vrai qu'on se dit
pour la rentrée elle nous montre elle
nous montre une image d'Emmanuel Macron
non mais on peut on peut en écrivant je
me suis dit c'est vrai que je me fous
pas une image d'Emmanuel Macron mais en
fait c'est plus que ça quand je dis je
suis en train de vendre ma chronique non
un faux Emmanuel Macron répond à vos
questions 24 heures sur 24 sur twitch
mon ministre préféré certainement pas
toi avec une question aussi dénuée de
sens le ton et volontairement
sarcastique et drôle sauf quand on lui
demande un poème sur sa femme Brigitte
m'amuse ma reine élégante tu es mon rock
ma plus grande confidante un internaute
qui lui a demandé ce qui était la poudre
de perlimpinpin et voici ce que lui a
répondu à l'intelligence artificielle
écoutez
la poudre de perlimpinpin c'est comme
tes connaissances sans politique ça ne
sert à rien et ça fait juste illusion
allez passe à autre chose c'est Anissa
Yaris ingénieur spécialisé en
intelligence artificielle qui a mis au
point ce chat avec d'autres
personnalités disponibles comme le
général de Gaulle pour gagner un
cache-cache il faut être rusé comme un
renard et rapide comme un éclair dans la
crevette frappe
c'était une vitesse fulgurante plus
rapide qu'une balle de fusil
aucune coquille ni carapace ne lui
résiste
[Musique]
c'est le coup de poing le plus rapide du
monde animal
donc d'un côté ce patron milliardaire de
Twitter qu'on doit appeler x désormais
contre Mark Zuckerberg ce patron
milliardaire de facebook qu'on doit
appeler meta désormais les deux imaginez
quasius dans une cage de MMA vous savez
ce sport
c'est extrêmement violent le mix mashall
heart les coûts sont quasiment tous
permis et c'était vraiment censé se
passer ce week-end le 26 août finalement
rien alors
[Musique]
[Rires]
Donald Trump fait feu de tout bois alors
que d'autres l'auraient caché lui s'est
servi de sa mugshot sa photo d'identité
judiciaire le cliché publié sur des
T-shirts et des mugs fait vendre bilan
il a récolté 6 millions et demi d'euros
depuis son arrestation jeudi en Géorgie
de quoi booster sa campagne à
l'investiture républicaine
tu fais peur un peu quand même
évacuation de la peur enclencher
[Musique]
[Rires]
en quelques secondes l'autoroute A43 et
la départementale parallèle sont
entièrement recouvertes vers 17h15 hier
deux voitures et un camion y échappent
in extremis ces images amateurs
témoignent de la force de l'éboulement
700 mètres cubes de bloc rocheux ce sont
détachés avant de dévaler la pente sur
cette autre vidéo amateur on voit
clairement la paroi se décrocher sur
plusieurs dizaines de mètres au total
700 mètres cubes se sont écroulés il n'y
a pas eu de blessés
ce matin on mesure la violence de cet
effondrement
ils sont venus en famille profiter de la
plage cet été beaucoup de sangliers ont
été aperçus dans le Var à Saint-Tropez
Ramatuelle ou encore Sainte-Maxime sur
les nombreuses vidéos publiées en ligne
les mammifères semblent peu déranger par
les touristes à qui ils veulent bien un
peu de nourriture comme dans cette
poussette sans bébé dedans le phénomène
concerne surtout le sud-est de la France
mais pas seulement la à Vieux-Boucau
dans les Landes un sanglier se fait
chasser de la plage par un gendarme pour
ce poulpe diourne la chasse à l'affût
devient soudain plus difficile quand un
banc de poisson lui barre la route
certains jours il est même plus simple
d'abandonner la partie
[Musique]
et de retourner se coucher